[Music]
no it really doesn't concern me it's not
my decision
and
i've never
worried about it before and don't worry
about it now and i won't worry about it
in the future
i'll just do the best job i can do
freddie kitchen's brown's head coach
talking about his job security the
problem is the best job he can do hasn't
been good enough two and six
so far and the loss to the broncos look
you and i both picked the browns to win
because we didn't know what to think
about brandon allen we figured the
browns finally the schedule's gonna
start to solve and they could win some
games they had a big win last year in
denver close ones all right i thought i
was like i thought i picked like a 1917
game but go ahead here's the thing
though yeah freddie kitchen's
first year on the job
really wasn't groomed to be a head coach
tony dungy i've heard you say that yeah
tony dungy on friday talked about how he
was actively groomed for four years by
dennis green should be a head coach
freddie kitchens was minding his own
business as a running backs coach last
year then all of a sudden he wakes up
and he's the interim offensive
coordinator and then he does well enough
in the back half of the season that they
make him the head coach when did he ever
spend time learning how to be a head
coach he's learning the job on the fly
and the problem is the bar was too high
there was no way for him to effectively
pull the expectations in and now here
they are at two and six same old browns
are going to be hard-pressed to finish
better than they were last year that
when they were so they're gonna have to
go six and two to be better than they
were last year i don't see it happening
and here's the thing that really stunned
me chris i posted a poll last night very
simple question freddy kitchen's one and
done question mark there have been over
48 000 votes so far and it's 94 yes we
cannot get in this day and age in the
united states of america or the world at
large 94 of the people to agree on
anything on anything what day is it you
can't get 94 agreement on that and it's
amazing to me that people feel that way
i'm withholding judgment i'm actually
gonna be in the six percent for now
because i don't know how much of this is
really his fault and could he get better
next year will he learn the job on the
fly i don't know but so far it has not
been very good for freddie kitchen no it
hasn't and you know i i understand the
concerns and i think you know the point
you've been making that point a little
bit and you know the way tony dungy
explained it is is perfect yeah a lot of
guys that do become head coaches in the
nfl it's on their radar to where they're
at least you know an assistant coach
somewhere for a year knowing oh i got
interviews last year as a head coach and
you know the head coach now knows i
might be a head coach and he he kind of
takes me under his wings and and opens
the door every now and then to show some
of his logic to what's being done you
know to make the donuts be you know
behind the scenes whatever they you know
how they say uh
this is going to be an interesting thing
that's a hell of a thing yeah you like
that what it takes to make the donuts
behind the scenes whatever they say i'm
gonna put that on a t-shirt please do uh
you might need a big t-shirt okay but or
small letters i don't know where this is
gonna go okay like i can look at adam
gase and the jets and go
a lot of the issues that jets have and
it hasn't been a good look and gase
hasn't been great don't get me wrong but
there's a roster built by a guy who's
not there any longer and we can see why
he's not there any longer there's
nothing on the roster that's really that
good uh with cleveland there's plenty of
good on the roster and you just wonder
sometimes do they need more of a strong
been there proven commodity to be the
head coach that's the only thing i
question there and maybe that happens
and maybe it does happen we'll see
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports